[Music]
my name is deb gruenfeld and i'm a
faculty member at stanford in the
graduate school of business
one of my favorite classes is called
managing groups and teams and i'm going
to share five key takeaways from that
class today
[Music]
there's no one way to design teams for
success
you have to start with the end in mind
often when we talk about building a team
we think of people horse who do i like
to work with and how can i get as many
stars as possible
but we believe you can't know who to
work with or how to structure your team
until you know what's needed for the
team to succeed
teams should be designed around a clear
engaging direction
a goal
so the building of the team is dictated
by the specific outcomes we hope to
achieve
when making choices about how to design
teams for different purposes there are
two key dimensions to choose from
the first is that you have to decide
what to do about diversity that is
you want to maximize diversity to
prioritize learning outcomes and sharing
different perspectives and inclusion
or do you want to control for the
effects of diversity by making sure team
members goals are aligned and an
agreement can be reached so the team can
move forward
the second big question in addition to
what to do about diversity is what to do
about hierarchy
whether to make sure participation and
influence are even
or to make sure that the voices of
experts or key stakeholders are more
influential than the voices of people
who are more competent but whose
opinions shouldn't matter as much
your choices will depend again
on what's necessary for the team to
succeed
it's not enough to compose teams with
people who create the appearance of
surface level diversity and assume the
rest will take care of itself
unless you take steps to ensure that the
deeper level diverse perspectives and
experiences
and knowledge that you're seeking
actually surface
and receive attention
there's a good chance that they won't
so it's important to use processes in
general that normalize raising
alternative points of view asking
questions and challenging others
assumptions
these things don't tend to happen on
their own in teams
especially in diverse groups where
levels of psychological safety might be
low
expertise
rarely predicts influence in teams
while things like physical
attractiveness and gender
predict influence very well
in part this is because teens fear
conflict and are motivated to reach
agreement as quickly as possible
it's important to be aware of these
dynamics so that we can all individually
take steps to counteract them
it's good to have ways of drawing out
quieter members
and gently quieting others
to create space
for less hierarchical
more equal participation
many people think it's always better to
bring a more participative collaborative
empowering hands-off approach to leading
teams but in reality
managing or leading a team is a delicate
balancing act
between imposing enough top-down
structure and control
while inviting enough bottom-up
participation
imposing direction and structure can
feel oppressive or paternalistic
but failing to articulate and reinforce
a clear vision of success can leave team
members feeling lost and unmotivated
the takeaway here
is that it's not a leader's job to
manage teammates feelings or be as
likable as possible
the job is to manage the team's
performance and outcomes in a way
that engages stretches and develops the
team and guides them forward to success
[Music]
[Music]
i was not a serious student in high
school i mostly was interested in boys
and going to parties with my friends so
i think it has come actually as quite a
shock to many of the people who knew me
when i was younger that
i'm a professor here
[Music]
you